- The margin presented a
target of opportunity for us.
Look, like I said,
this is my fourth term,
and I'm tired of the
way this place works.
I think it's deeply corrupt.
I think the lobbyists run
the show most of the times.
I think people are
more interested
in servicing their
PAC fundraiser than
they are the needs
of their constituents.
And it's a grift game.
And what facilitates
that grift game is
an entire sophisticated
structure that ensures
that no one's really
responsible for the legislating.
(dramatic music)
- All right.
We're still in DC.
I'm still Dave Rubin.
It's still the Rubin Report.
And joining me today
is the congressman
from Florida's first district
and a first time
Rubin Report guest,
which is really bizarre to me,
Matt Gaetz.
Matt, how are you?
- Good to see you.
Thanks for having me.
- This is weird to me that
we've never sat down before.
I feel like you've been
fighting with everybody, and...
- I feel like I know you
because I watch the show, so.
- How am I doing?
- Great. I mean, you're
getting the message out.
- Killing it in the hair game.
That's really what I
wanna focus on mostly.
- You know, when Dave
Brat lost in Virginia,
it was sad to see a
colleague I respected go,
but that was when I got
the best hair in Congress,
and so there's
some up and comers.
Kiley out of California, he's
got great hair, great height.
I'm worried about him.
- Is that mostly what's
going on behind the scenes?
Like everyone's like
who has the best hair?
Who has the worst hair plugs?
That's pretty much
what's happening, right?
- I wish there was
a border bill up.
How about that for a lead?
I wish that we were talking
about internal enforcement
and asylum reform.
One thing that frustrates me
a little is that we've passed
two bills to deal with the
borders of Indian tribes and not
yet a bill to deal with
the border of our country.
So I wouldn't give our congress
an A-plus yet until we get
the work of the people done.
- I like it. You're going
right into the issues.
So let's do it right there.
Well, actually gimme one
minute on just Matt Gaetz 101
for the people that just don't
know your history at all.
- Oh, sure.
- And then we'll get
into all the specifics.
- I'm a country lawyer
from North Florida,
served in our state legislature
proudly for six years.
I chaired what was the
equivalent of our Ways and Means
Committee, fought for low
taxes, good regulatory reform.
I was probably a more
libertarian-leaning
member of the
State House than I
am of the Congress,
but when President Trump was
running, the juices started to
stir to do a little
more for my country.
I ran.
I got here.
I'm in my fourth term now and
eager to continue the work.
I think that we've got
one-half of one-third of the
government right now, and every
day is really a test in how
to exercise leverage
effectively, and you
can overplay that
and underplay that, but we're
working to curate that balance
in a way that makes
life better for people.
- So let's talk about that
leverage for a minute,
because just about two hours
ago I had Congressman Dan
Crenshaw in here, and you guys
were obviously on opposite
sides of everything that went
down with McCarthy and the
leadership, but that was my
whole purpose of coming to DC.
I wanted to sit down with guys
that were on every side of
every issue.
So you basically led the
fight against McCarthy.
Were you planning on doing that?
Did it just kind of
materialize out of nowhere?
And then did it become
like a monster unto itself
once it started?
- Well, I think there were
a lot of people who took
leadership roles on
different issue sets.
Not every person required
the same concessions to allow
McCarthy to ascend
to the speakership.
Some people are
more fiscal hawks,
some people are
more border hawks,
some people are oversight hawks.
And so within those different
groups, there were a lot of
voices that emerged and so I
wouldn't characterize myself
the leader, but we
realized the opportunity...
- Well, I guess maybe the media
at least kind of framed you
as you were kind of the one...
- The media does like
talking about me a lot.
- They do like
talking about you.
Well, you hang out with
the orange guy a lot.
There's a lot,
you know, come on.
- Well, you know, he's a
fun guy to hang out with.
So the margin presented a
target of opportunity for us.
Look, like I said,
this is my fourth term and I'm
tired of the way this place
works.
I think it's deeply corrupt.
I think the lobbyists run
the show most of the times.
I think people are
more interested in
servicing their PAC
fundraiser than they are the
needs of their constituents.
And it's a grift game.
And what facilitates that
grift game is an entire
sophisticated structure
that ensures that no one's
really responsible for
the legislating, right?
If we had to take individual
votes on individual departments
and authorizations and bills
and spending, then we would
probably be held to account
to a greater degree by the
people in this country.
But instead what you get
is every year or so some
multi-thousand page bill that
you get a day, day and a half
to read, and the whole deal
is thumbs up or thumbs down on
the whole thing.
And then you're left with the
decision of voting for a bunch
of crap you don't agree with
or leaving out the widows
and the orphans and the veterans
and the military and things
that every American
would care about.
And we had to force upon the
system a better way to deal
with legislating
as an enterprise.
And that had features in
policy, features in personnel,
and features in procedure,
and that's what we
were working through.
- So I heard you on Tim Pool's
podcast talking about just
that, these massive bills that
you get and that nobody can
read it as you just laid out,
and it's a whole bunch of stuff,
but if you don't vote for it,
someone's gonna
die and all that.
So I wanna talk about
the specifics of that,
but did you feel like you
actually at the end got the
concessions, and how do you
know that you're actually gonna
get them?
You know what I mean?
Like do you have a piece of
paper that's sitting in your
office, you and McCarthy,
to go on this stuff.
- Well, the ultimate
accountability tool
isn't a piece of
paper.
The accountability tool is
that any one member can go and
force a vote on the
speaker at any time
and, you know, throw it...
- So that was the main
concession, right?
- That was the enforcement
tool for the other substantive
concessions, right?
But I mean, I'll gladly go
into the substance of these
things and, sure, we
add documents that
we exchange back and
forth with offers and
suggestions and revisions.
In any negotiation, you never
get exactly what you want.
But I recall going into
the speaker's office with
Scott Perry and Lauren Boebert
before the balloting began,
and we laid out what we
thought was a pretty reasonable
proposal to the speaker.
And he laughed at us and said
we just wanted the opportunity
to have that power, but
that resided in the speaker,
not in our group.
And then ultimately we got to
something that was far better
than had been rejected and
ultimately far better for the
House of Representatives.
And I don't say that as
a criticism of McCarthy.
I actually think it's to
his great credit that he was
willing to see past a reflexive
opposition to things like
the one member motion
to vacate the chair.
He had originally said
that was a red line.
He would never cross it.
He would never go there.
And had he been
stubborn about that,
he probably wouldn't be speaker,
and it would've been worse
for the country and for the
House and for the party.
So his ability to, I think,
move past his red lines
started that process
of building trust.
- What do you make how it
creates strange bedfellows outta
people. So for example,
Trump is backing McCarthy,
but you're a Trump guy,
you're going against McCarthy.
The base doesn't
seem to like McCarthy
but the base loves Trump.
There were so many just odd
pieces to the whole thing.
- I guess. I mean, we're
complicated people.
No two people see
everything the same.
I know people view me
as a Trump acolyte,
and certainly I spend time
with the former president.
I like him, I support him,
but even President Trump and
I see some issues differently.
And when you have a high
intensity negotiation,
different people can go to
different corners and make
different demands,
and I think ultimately
we got to a good result,
but I don't believe that anyone
deserves praise yet because
all we have developed
is a toolkit,
and it's a toolkit that's really
unlike any I've ever had as
a member of Congress.
But if all we do is admire
the tools and talk about how
great it was that we got the
tools and what a negotiation
delivered the tools to the
toolkit and we don't use them,
then we are part of the
fraudulent system that
screws people over.
- So how do you
wanna use the tools?
Today, you're in DC.
If you go over to the capitol,
start chatting with these guys,
how do you want to actually
exercise this stuff?
- Well, one that's got me a
little worked up as we're having
this discussion is the border.
There's a commitment that
Speaker McCarthy made that the
border plan that had been
previously endorsed by the Texas
delegation would be
coming to the floor.
And right now we don't even
have a border vote scheduled in
the House Judiciary Committee.
We were supposed to right now
be preparing for an upcoming
hearing, and the
immigration bills were
taken off the agenda.
So I'm a little
frustrated about that.
I want to give grace in
deference where it's due,
if there are some details
still to work out.
But one substantive concession
is to get a bill to the floor
that says that we detain people
if we have the space or we
turn them away.
It's H.R. 29.
And we need to get to the
business of doing that.
The other is the budget.
We have to start
moving individual
appropriations bills to
the floor so we can
evaluate every agency,
every layer of every agency.
That has to start
getting scheduled in the
Appropriations Committee.
We were promised a
vote on term limits.
I think that a lot of
these things, by the way,
are gonna fail that
I'm asking for.
- Right.
- Term limits vote will fail.
- The real changes to secure
the border might fail if
pro-amnesty Republicans
don't hang with us.
The bottom line is
I'm okay with that.
You see the leadership in
both parties have this view
that it's this great
embarrassment and
this great tumult
if you put something on the
floor that doesn't have the
votes.
I actually think that
can be revealing.
And sometimes you have to go
through an iterative process to
get to a good work product.
And whether it's Obamacare or
any number of other bills that
don't get that scrutiny,
you end up with all these
terrible unintended consequences
if you don't do it.
- So when you talk about
these freaking giant, well,
they're not like this. They're
actually like almost to the
ceiling high, some
of these things.
So they hand this to you,
and you basically don't know
who's written it, right?
Or it's lobbyists that
have half-written it.
- I know who's written it. Yeah.
- It's the interest groups.
- Yeah.
- I mean, what this town runs
on are the interest groups
that plow money into
the political system.
And it's more
sophisticated than that,
but that is really the rock
upon which they built their
church.
But it's also like in
a lot of these offices,
you get underpaid staff
working for the taxpayer.
And a lot of them their dream
is to go work as lobbyists
or for these interest groups.
So they end up in some
places becoming the valets of
the special interests.
Now, fortunately, my staff is...
we're a pirate ship,
so everybody comes on board
and understands that we got a
different kind of mission.
But in a lot of places, that
is actually part of the swamp
that concerns me.
But they're able to hide
in that corrupt system.
If you have individual
scrutiny of the bills,
you get to flush
out all the varmint,
and then you know what happens.
And getting personnel appointed
is another critical thing
for conservatives.
We have people like Thomas
Massie, Chip Roy, Ralph Norman,
who we trust do not fall
victim to that system.
They have long histories
of standing up for their
constituents, and so we put
the three of them on the
Rules Committee.
Now guess what?
Before stuff gets to the floor,
we're working out our
issues in advance,
we're getting some of the pork
and special favors for the
lobby corps weeded out.
And then on the
Appropriations Committee,
we also demanded spots for
additional conservatives.
We demanded that one of our
existing members have reins
over a subcommittee to be
able to constrain some of the
social spending.
So, I mean, these
are real concessions
that Speaker McCarthy
has delivered on.
And then we've just got a lot
of other stuff gestating in
the pipeline and, as you
can tell, I'm anxious
to get that done.
- What do you think
the Republicans can
do to message this
stuff better because it's...
I've been telling all my guests,
and I'm gonna sit down with
with Chip and Thomas tomorrow.
Ron Johnson was here today.
I'm sitting down with
as many people as I can.
And one of the things that
seems odd to me is that
Peter Thiel always says
we have the evil party
and the stupid party,
and it's like the Democrats
are the evil party, obviously.
But then there's this other
party that, as frustrated as
people may be with them, they
just don't seem to want to
cross that divide.
What do you think
Republicans can do on that?
- You know, we face
exquisite headwinds.
The censorship industrial
complex is real,
and actually we're using
the power we have in the
Weaponization subcommittee,
also a concession that was a
part of the speaker's race,
to expose that censorship
industrial complex to haul the
people forward that really
are the puppet masters that
engage in the shadow banning
and the programming of the
mainstream media and
the government threats
to big tech that
shape what people see
and what they believe.
So it's hard to talk about
the efficacy of one's message
when you're not talking about
the systems that proliferate
that message.
So I think that is a threshold
issue you have to address.
Look, you always want a
movement with the best messages
and the best messengers.
And fortunately for us, the
left is somewhere between a
nursing home escape and
a carnival freak show.
- Yeah.
- And so we've got a
lot of running room,
and I actually think we
have great messengers.
I mean, you mentioned
Dan Crenshaw earlier.
There are a lot of issues that
he and I see differently in
the House, but that's a guy
who knows how to carry a
message.
He does it so effectively.
I admire that about him.
- He actually said the
same thing about you.
So there you go.
- Yeah.
And I think that right now the
interesting exercise we're in
with a four-seat majority is
we have to think about things
that we can unify behind
that go from Matt Gaetz to
a Mike Lawler or a Brian
Fitzpatrick or a David Valadeo,
someone more in the
political center.
And acknowledging that and
working through that actually
makes us stronger as
a team going forward.
And I don't say that as
some cheeky bullshit.
You look at the debt limit
that we have right now.
What are we gonna demand as
a part of the negotiation on
the debt limit?
I've proposed demanding work
requirements on a lot of these
social safety net programs,
not because that's the
only thing I'd like to do.
I'd like to zero out the
Federal Department of Education.
I'd like to zero out the ATF.
I'd like to zero out
the Department of Labor.
I'd like to do all those things,
but I recognize that those
demands are likely to fizzle in
the broader construct we find
ourselves in with Biden in the
White House and with the
Senate in Democrat hands.
And so what are the ways that
we can juxtapose Joe Biden,
not to me, but to Bill Clinton,
who was willing to sit down
and work out work requirements.
So that's how a
four-seat majority
informs on the real-time
decisions we're making this
week about a consequential
issue like the debt limit.
- So I've asked this of
everybody that's coming in here.
I mean, you mentioned how
it's, what did you say, it's an
old age home and a clown
circus, something like that,
or a freak show.
It's like is there anyone to
talk to that you can work with
on things?
- Oh, sure.
- You know, on the other side?
- Yeah.
I mean there are people in
both parties to whom it is
worthless to speak because
they are vessels through which
the special interests operate,
and the only thing that's gonna
guide them is some corrupt
influence. Sometimes
it's campaign money.
Sometimes it's some family
member of their's that gets a
no-show job that
enhances their lifestyle.
Sometimes it's what their
stock portfolio looks like.
But there are also very
good people on both sides,
I would say, that want to
move the country forward.
Increasingly, I think there
are too many Democrats who
actually explicitly root
against the country,
and they believe that
is virtuous because
they think that if
America is weakened as a nation
that somehow we will treat
each other better
and be more just,
and they're actually just as
dumb as the neocons who believe
that you can go behind every
Middle Eastern sand dune and
build some Jeffersonian
democracy after a
regime change war.
I'm not for regime change there,
and I'm not for changing the
fundamentals of American life
that have made us the
envy of the world.
I think that the deconstruction
is occurring on the left
right now to the family,
to the education setting,
to law enforcement,
and as conservatives we have
to unite to resist that.
- Do you think there's anything
that the Democrats can do to
reverse that, or do you
think that ship has sailed?
Meaning, we played a
clip this morning...
- They don't invite me
to their bunco parties.
- You know, we played
a clip this morning,
It's like AOC,
you guys passed the parents'
rights and education thing and
she's calling it fascism.
Hakeem Jeffries is saying
they don't want to teach about
the Holocaust.
It's just like
lies and craziness.
Is there anyone in there
that can sort of stem that,
or do you think
that's just about...
- Well, broadly, I don't know
the answer to that question,
but I do think we have to be
willing to create alliances
around issue sets where
we may have common ground.
Take, for example, the
surveillance state that we have.
I get real squeamish about the
powers that the Patriot Act
and other laws have fused into
the national security state
to deprive Americans of their
liberties often in the absence
of constitutional protections.
And I can find Democrats like
Zoe Lofgren on the Judiciary
Committee, or Ro Khanna in
the progressive delegation,
who will actually work with
me to try to build enduring
coalitions against
an establishment that
also includes both
Republicans and Democrats.
I don't know why we're in Syria.
I think that that is a
foolish conquest for the
United States.
I think that our service
members are sitting ducks in
many cases guarding oil rigs
where for relatively low cost
the Iranians can send
lethal drone strikes.
So I force a vote on whether
or not to withdraw from Syria.
I get 20 minutes a time,
the Republicans get
20 minutes a time,
the Democrats get
20 minutes a time.
All of the time controlled
by each of the parties was
given to people to debate in
favor of America staying in
Syria.
- Right.
- It shows you on some of these
issues from surveillance to
foreign policy how it's not
really the red team against the
blue team.
It's more about the
establishment against
the rest of us.
- You must be kind of
proud that it does seem,
at least from what I can tell,
that the anti-war sentiment
does seem to be picking up
that, you know, even if you
watched the way when Tucker
took all the statements from the
presidential candidates
about Ukraine, you know,
and DeSantis was a little more
in the Trump camp than people
wanted, then he
slightly moved on it.
But the fact that the whole
machine came down on him...
- He was right.
- I mean, you're like
a DeSantis apostle.
Why is it that Ron moved
away from the America first
position and had to start
sounding more like Piers Morgan?
- Well, it's interesting and
people can watch my video
from the next day.
I thought the statement
on Tucker was perfect.
I actually thought it
was basically perfect.
It's a territorial dispute.
We can't solve all
the world's problems,
and we've got our own problems.
That seemed good enough to me.
I should say I'm not a
surrogate for him or anything,
so it is what it is.
He moved off it a little bit.
What did he say after?
Yeah, I'm not even sure, but
I know just over the last
couple of days...
Oh, the Piers interview.
He said "war criminal,"
and I think that's
what got everybody.
He said Putin's a war criminal.
- And he started to parrot
some McCain/Romney lines also.
- Oh, the gas station line.
That was the big one.
Yeah.
I don't know. I don't know.
What do you think?
- I think that DeSantis probably
had the right energy in the
Tucker interview more than in
the Piers Morgan interview.
And he and I served
together in the Congress,
and I enthusiastically supported
his campaign for governor,
served as his transition chair
when he took the position.
Very proud of the work
that he's done in Florida.
But we always would squabble
a bit over foreign policy
because I read his book
and it leaned a little more
into the Boltonista view of
the world than my view of the
world, and so we would have
friendly squabbles about foreign
policy at times.
He's very bright.
He understands the
world very well.
But I have a different view
of what America's focus
should be.
And when we try to become
the world's policeman and the
world's piggy bank, not only
does that drain us of our
treasure and the blood
of our bravest patriots,
it's often counterproductive.
- Yeah. I'll be totally honest.
I mean, and this is
what I said to Crenshaw,
who I happen to agree more
with you on this than Crenshaw,
to me, if nothing else, putting
aside all of the policies,
we are governed by a bunch of
complete morons at the moment
basically, so why
would I trust...
They can't do
anything right here.
Why would I trust that we
can just endlessly give money
across the world and
that's gonna fix anything,
even if you put aside the
philosophic isolationist versus
doing stuff policy.
Yeah.
- I also get to have spirited
intelligent debates with
Mr. Crenshaw on the subject
and I enjoy those and I
appreciate his perspective,
but you look at
our military now.
During the Afghanistan
withdrawal,
the fact that they
sequenced it incorrectly,
the fact that they didn't
downstream the authority to the
American snipers to take out
the suicide bomber resulted in
the loss of 13 lives.
Then we didn't even get
the redemption right.
When we were gonna go have the
vengeance killing against the
ISIS guys who were planning
the plot against Americans,
we accidentally killed
a family in a van.
So if Taiwan is invaded by
China and we get in the fight,
are we're gonna
miss and hit Japan.
- Right.
- I look at our military right
now and I'm inspired every
day by the folks who put the
uniform on and love our nation.
- Yes.
- But they are not well served
by the clowns who are making
the calls at the senior
levels of the Pentagon.
What did these guys get right?
They told us that the Ghani
government was gonna stay and
fight for at least six months.
And they told us that the
Ukrainians were gonna be gone in
six weeks.
Do you trust these people to
make accurate assessments about
literally anything
at this point?
- No, I don't.
So the other thing I've been
asking everybody is do you
think this is incompetence
or willful destruction of
everything that makes
sense. How about that?
- I struggle with that
decision because, honestly,
I try to not judge
people's motives.
- Yeah.
- But at some point, the good
book says you have to judge
the tree by the fruit.
And I'm looking at
the decision calculus
and what it leads to,
and it is just unworthy of
my constituents who will go
anywhere and fight anyone
because they love this country,
and they don't ask
the tough questions.
They do whatever they're told.
And so it is incumbent upon
us to be willing to ask those
questions.
And when Secretary of Defense
and the chairman come before
the House Armed
Services Committee, I
think I'll be asking
some tough questions.
- So I think one thing
that people see is, okay,
so you bring out a bunch of
people to talk about big tech,
the Twitter executives,
or this one or that one,
and we expose some
of the nonsense,
but nothing ever
happens after, right?
That it's just like, okay, wow,
you got the guy who traded the
email with the FBI agent to
censor somebody, but then the
next day it's like everyone
still has their jobs.
No one in government
was hauled out.
So what about that?
What about getting some of
the people that were doing
some of the surveillance
stuff that was involved with
Twitter and Facebook and
everything else and getting
them to testify.
Aren't those the people
that should be testifying
not just the kind of half-assed
Twitter executive who was or
wasn't doing the best he could?
- Well, I think that's
what we're building to.
- Yeah.
- My assessment is that
that is precisely how this
investigation crescendos.
The people in our government
who believe that they should
substitute their judgment about
what is true or false, about
what is disinformation or not,
for the judgment of Americans
who I think actually can
compare sources and review
information.
Like the pro-censorship crowd.
They have such a low
view of the rest of us.
- Yeah.
- They have to be
there to protect us.
Well actually that's
not how it works at all.
And when you ask
about consequences,
the United States Congress
cannot go throw handcuffs
on anyone, and that's probably
for pretty good reason.
Right now we have a Justice
Department that is pretty
recalcitrant to any
referral that we make.
Even if these people tell us
to get bent when we send them
subpoenas, that'll be
an interesting fight.
And so we have to go through
this accommodation process to
try to bleed out of the
executive branch the people,
the records, the admissions
that I think make the case.
The real question is
how to use the leverage,
which I believe is the
power of the subpoena
and the power of the purse.
That is what Speaker McCarthy
said in his acceptance speech,
and it was beautiful
and it's true.
And so we cannot continue to
fund this weaponized government
against our people if those
authorities stay in place.
And if we do not bake into any
budget deal a restriction on
what they're able to do to us.
- What about the fact that it
seems like so few people that
are asking the questions at
these hearings have any freaking
clue what they're talking about?
It's almost not everything,
but I would say
what it comes to...
- They should just
yield me all the time.
That's what you're
saying, right?
That's allowed.
They could just
send me the time.
- Let Gaetz do it.
He's a little younger.
- Jordan.
There's a bunch of good ones.
Mike Johnson, Dan
Bishop, Harriet Hageman.
We've got a lot of good ones.
- Yeah. She's something else.
- She's very effective.
- Yeah.
But really, especially
with the text stuff,
you get these people up there
that clearly don't even know
how to open up an app on
their phone and they're like,
it's just so stupid.
- We are not going to be able
to defeat big tech if our
leaders on the front line
are not digital natives.
That's why this next generation
coming behind me is so
important to win the battle
against big tech and to win the
battles against transhumanism
that are not even fully
emerging yet, right?
And so I view the geriatric
millennials among us as really
the bridge to try to start the
fires that the Zoomers behind
us will have to really take
up because it fundamentally
shapes their life.
But if you've been
waiting around...
- Geriatric millennial,
that's a Gen-Z'er basically?
- No, no. Geriatric
millennials are like the
old millennials, like the
first millennials, you know.
- Right.
So where does that
put Gen-Z then?
- Well, Gen-Z, they're the
Zoomers, they're behind us.
- Oh, I'm sorry. Not
Gen-Z, I mean Gen-X.
I'm Gen-X.
What happened to us?
- Yeah, no. Gen-X.
You guys listened to
all the metal bands,
and you're not really digital
natives at all, right?
I mean, Gen-X actually believes
that you should come to work
early and stay late and that
the way you moved up in the
world was by working harder.
You guys were getting into the
workforce in the Reagan '80s.
The Gen-Xers have no idea
how to talk to the Zoomers,
who show up and say like, "I'd
like to discuss my work-life
balance with you."
That's totally foreign
to the Gen-Xers.
But for us, here's the
key policy question.
Do you carve up big tech in
the courts or do you reshape
these companies legislatively?
And frankly it's what divides
people like me and Jim Jordan.
- Right.
- The Jim Jordan approach
would be strip them of their
immunities like section 230 and
then allow the trial lawyers
to go feast on them.
It's kind of like what we did
to big tobacco in the '90s,
and I just don't know if that
is enough firepower to shoot
at the Death Star
that is big tech.
I believe we have to go more
the direction of the Bell
breakup in telecom where
you literally force,
but you use force of
law, to say that Meta
has to alienate Instagram.
You say that Google has
to alienate YouTube,
and you have to reshape and
break up these companies
without going through the
litigation process for another
seven, eight years.
- Is this where you would say
that old school republicanism
just kind of doesn't work?
- Yes.
- We played a clip on my show
about two, three weeks ago
where Mike Pence
was on CNBC saying,
Well, DeSantis went too far
by taking away some special
rights from Disney.
And it was like,
well wait a minute.
- The government gave
Disney those rights.
- Exactly, exactly.
And it just read to me as
so out of touch with what
people want, right?
There's also Sea World.
They don't have special rights.
- What is the constituency
for Mike Pence?
- Right.
- I'm just wondering.
- I don't know.
- Other than Sunday show
bookers and like CNN and the
mainstream media...
- I think he knows that.
I don't think he's running.
- You don't?
- I don't think so.
I think he knows that.
I don't know anyone.
What is that?
- Okay.
I'm wondering where I've
gotta go to meet the
Mike Pence voter.
- Maybe Mike Pence's house.
- You must.
- All right.
So you're a Florida congressman.
You're torn with the
freaking red-assed...
Where did you get the jacket
like that? That red jacket?
- Oh, I lifted it off
of a maitre'd on the way
into the event.
- I actually believe you.
I sort of do believe
you, but okay.
Look, you're a
Florida congressman,
you obviously like DeSantis
but you're doing your thing
with Trump.
From where I sit as
someone that lived in Cali,
moved to Florida,
my life is immeasurably better.
I brought two companies here
that are both flourishing.
Every one of my guys
over here all moved.
Everyone is seeing the
fruits of all of that stuff.
- By that standard, you
could vote for any Republican
governor in America.
- Well, I could certainly go
to any Republican state and be
better than it was in Cali.
- Sure.
- For sure.
I'm just seeing everything
work in Florida.
So how do you balance that in
that you live in a state that
clearly the governor's
doing the right thing,
you've got the super majorities
you want and it's cooking,
and then also obviously that
you like Trump and he obviously
has unfinished business
and that whole thing.
- Well, I am a DeSantis admirer.
I worked very hard
to get him elected,
but Florida has been under
unified Republican control since
the mid-90s.
And so there has been a
system in place in Florida to
advance school choice, to
have right sized environmental
regulations, to not overspend
on the state budget, to care
for our seniors
and the vulnerable.
And Ron DeSantis has done
an exquisite job as governor
leading that enterprise.
I know because I worked with
him as his transition chairman
and helped him hire some of
the great Floridians who've
helped him enact bold policies.
The time is right for Trump
in Washington right now
because that is a
different fight.
Being able to successfully
steer a successful state and to
chart a bullish course is
something I'm glad Ron's doing.
I hope he continues to do
it for his full eight years.
This place needs somebody
to come in with a sense of
retribution and a sense of, I
think, fight that is unique to
President Trump.
And being in Waco
this last weekend,
seeing the tens of
thousands of people show up,
there's something unique about
Trump and politics that I
think we need to have even a
chance against what we face
electorally.
- So I'll say to you what I've
been saying all along on my
show, which is, again,
I like 'em both.
If it ends up that Trump is
the president and DeSantis
remains my governor, I'll
be freaking thrilled.
That might be the
best situation truly,
and as a Floridian I can
fully make an argument that he
shouldn't run.
I fully get all that.
But what I would like to
see out of Trump right now,
since you have his ear, is
that you don't have to destroy
the guy like he's
trying to do it.
It seems to me that the
nicknames are not working,
that the pretending
that Florida...
- You don't think
Meatball Ron worked?
- Not really.
- You didn't?
John Oliver thought it worked.
This is a hot take, Dave.
- I don't agree with
John Oliver a lot.
- But you're agreeing
with John Oliver.
That's a problem.
- Listen.
I'm asking the question if
you thought Meatball Ron
just worked as a concept.
- It might be the
best of all of them,
but like desanctimonious.
Come on. It doesn't work.
He's not sanctimonious.
I'm not sure Trump knows
what the word means.
- Look, sometimes you gotta
go through a few iterations
on a nickname in the game
before you land at one.
- Okay.
But putting aside the nickname,
the point of trying to
destroy the guy that is the
standard bearer of a
Republican as governor I think
is just misguided.
I think that that's misguided.
I get politics is nasty.
- Yeah. Nobody pitches underhand
here. It's the presidency.
- Yeah.
- I think that when someone
puts himself forward
for the contest...
I'm telling you I'm
hearing a lot of that,
that people are like...
- Oh sure.
None of us like that.
None of us like when folks
we admire are disagreeing
and fighting with one another.
- Yeah.
- But I certainly don't
begrudge either for engaging in
that enterprise because
it's competitive.
Look, I mean, you know how
you get the strongest lions,
because if there's a strong
male lion and he comes up on a
less strong male lion that's
got some female lions around,
he kills the male lion and
mates with the females, right?
That's how it goes in
the animal kingdom,
and I'm not entirely sure
that politics is all that much
different.
- Every now and again you end
up with a bunch of dead lions,
and then you've got
Democrats in power,
which is a bigger
problem probably.
- Yeah.
They're the hyenas I
think in in my metaphor.
- Exactly.
What's next?
What's next for you?
I mean, you're gonna fight
as this thing's going.
It seems like Republicans are
kind of moving a little bit.
You've got some stuff
out of McCarthy.
What else do wanna
see in this town?
- I'm thinking very short term.
I'm thinking let's get a good
deal on the debt limit that
does not bankrupt this country.
I'm looking after that and an
appropriations process that I
hope will reset the table for
a decade long past my time
here as a congressman.
And I hope that the things
that I fought for during the
speaker's race will become the
expectation and the baseline
going forward.
And that the next generation
can come in with even better
ideas about how to empower the
membership and how to really
expose the extent to which we
don't get to make decisions on
far too many matters that are
of great consequence to our
constituents.
And we've gotta do a
better job fixing that.
And I want to use the
tools in the toolkit.
I'm tired of staring at 'em.
I often get chastised by my
colleagues that I'm impatient,
and I feel the anxiousness
of that in this moment.
- That probably should be the
ending, but I feel like I've
gotta ask you one more because
now having sat with you,
it's, again, the first time
that we ever met or anything.
You know if you listen to the
mainstream media talk about
you, you're some
kind of far right.
It's all nonsense, of course.
They say that about
all of us, so...
- Why do think they
hate me so much?
I've wondered this.
I don't fret over it.
- Now it's probably
just like enough,
you're around Trump enough,
it doesn't matter what you do.
Yeah. It just doesn't
matter what you say.
But they think I'm
far right, too.
- Oh yeah, you get it, too.
- I mean, New York
Times literally.
The front page of the
Sunday New York Times
said I was one of the
leaders of the alt-right.
So I could be stinking
you up, right?
- Better than being one
of the followers, I guess.
- Yeah. I guess. Exactly.
At least then you have
some ability to move them
or something.
But what about that portion of
it that you're also fighting?
It's not just that
you're fighting sort
of a deep state and
a system that's screwy and
Democrats that have kind of lost
their minds, but also just like
a media that is just so far
from the truth that it makes
just the messaging part of it
incredibly difficult.
- When members get to this
town and they go through the
first barrage of
unfair media criticism,
I try to advise them don't
let the process be the
punishment.
And often that's why the
media does what they do.
They want to shape
our legislative goals.
They wanna shape the things
that we're allowed to talk about
in civil society.
And I just don't give
in to the construct.
And I actually have a far higher
view of my fellow Americans
than I think the media does
because I think people see
through the bullshit.
I think people know who's
fighting for them and who isn't,
and in a town where a lot of
the politicians are just actors
reading the scripts from
lobbyists and staff who want to
become lobbyists, I think people
will forgive you a mistake
and an occasional disagreement
if they feel you are sincere
and that you care about them
and that you're actually
fighting for them and that's
how you spend your time.
So I try to convey
that in the work I do.
I know the media
conveys something else,
but I continue to get
overwhelmingly reelected.
And I really am heartened
by the prayers that I get,
that I feel from all over this
country from folks who want
to see that our work is done,
not for my sake, but for theirs.
- I know we may not see totally
eye to eye on everything,
but from one Floridian to
another, it's been a pleasure.
- Oh, thanks for having me, man.
- Yeah.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel,
check out our Politics Playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety of
topics, watch our full episode
playlist, all right over
here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.